[Musica]
[Applauso]
pluralia viene dall'aggettivo latino
pluralis significa molteplice non
unitario generale che riguarda
molti è un po' strano la mia prof di
latino sarebbe sicuramente molto
orgogliosa di me in questo momento
perché al
liceo per 3 anni consecutivi ho preso il
debito in latino Ecco la vedete qui in
splendida forma super soddisfatta del
suo studente modello e Salve prof E
vabbè continuiamo pluralia cioè le cose
plurali Questo è il tema che il tedx di
Sala Consilina ha scelto per la sua
prima edizione i plural sono le 1000 le
mila connessioni le interazioni Legami
che abitano noi stessi e le
cose stiamo vivendo un tempo molto
particolare perché siamo sempre più
vicini a noi stessi siamo sempre più
chiusi nella nostra bolla Eppure noi
siamo
pluralia viviamo in un sistema di
pluralia che a sua volta vive in un
sistema ancora più grande di pluralia
che a sua volta vive in un sistema
ancora più grande di pluralia e così via
all'infinito la cosa più interessante
ante è che questi sistemi dialoghino tra
di loro Siamo circondati da interazioni
Ecco proviamo ad immaginare queste
interazioni come flussi di corrente
elettrica È come se noi man mano le
stessimo spegnendo una per una
l'obiettivo di questo Ted è stato quello
di riattaccare la corrente riaccendere
la
luce Abbiamo affrontato delle tematiche
ben precise facendo però un passettino
più in là
rispetto alla definizione standard delle
cose ci siamo piati su una superficie
diversa nuova
inedita David Grossman uno scrittore
israeliano afferma che c'è un momento in
cui si compie un piccolo passo si devia
di 1 millimetro dalla solita via e si è
costretti a poggiare anche un secondo
piede e in quel momento si finisce in un
percorso
sconosciuto Ecco a abbiamo cercato con
questo Ted di dare vita a questo spazio
sospeso e da qui parte la mia domanda a
voi è mai capitato di cadere in un cesto
di
frutta a me sì Adesso vi racconto
Solitamente il sabato mattina vado al
mercato e questo sono io che vado al
mercato e facio una salita incredibile
per arrivarci e che grondo sudore da
ogni singolo paro del mio corpo e prendo
le solite cose che si prendono al
mercato vado dal mio fruttivendolo di
fiducia ormai siamo amici eh prendo
formaggi freschi stagionati pane ortaggi
ma c'è una cosa che prendo in
grandissime quantità la frutta Io compro
tantissima frutta quindi Ok vado da
Luigi prendo il mio solito cesto e torno
a casa Questo sono io che torno a casa
che faccio la salita di prima che è
diventata una discesa e sono anche molto
compiaciuto
di questa cosa arrivo a casa apro la
porta entro in salotto arrivo in cucina
e prendo tutta la frutta e la metto in
un cesto e inizio a
guardarla tipo così un pazzo che a casa
da solo guarda la frutta e la guardo
talmente tanto mi
sporgo talmente tanto che ci cado dentro
cado nel cesto di frutta e vado sempre
più giù e mi ritrovo in uno spazio
sospeso dove fluttua ogni cosa uno
spazio fatto tipo
così mi trovo sospeso in una
costellazione di frutta di tutta la
frutta che ho comprato ora voi vi
starete chiedendo ma perché questo C
parla di
frutta Avete presente quando vi dicono
che per far maturare alcuni frutti
dovete metterli vicino alle
ve lo dicono perché la mela è un frutto
climaterico
i frutti climaterici sono frutti che
anche una volta che sono stati colti
raccolti continuano a maturare sono in
grado di produrre etilene l'etilene È
l'ormone vegetale che si produce durante
la maturazione La mela è un frutto
climaterico e forse è il Primo tra tutti
perché è quello che contiene più Lene
poi ci sono le pere banane i chiwi le
pesche L'avocado e e così
via questa cosa qui non vi ricorda
qualcosa questa è frutta che fa maturare
altra frutta sono frutti che dialogano
tra di
loro sono pluralia e non è pazzesco e
allora torniamo alla nostra
costellazione di frutta e proviamo ad
immaginare ad ogni frutto come una delle
tematiche che sono state affrontate
durante questo Ted abbiamo parlato di
parità di
genere di economia
circolare di supercalcolo e intelligenza
artificiale di letteratura di
antropologia delle migrazioni e di
innovazione
sociale Questi frutti son tutti diversi
ma influenzano gli altri un po' come
tutte le tematiche che sono state
portate durante questo Ted
sono pluralia è divertente pensare che
per arrivare a questa cosa qui siamo
partiti da un cesto di frutta significa
che qualsiasi cosa è
collegabile qualsiasi cosa è pluralia e
ci avete fatto caso questa struttura di
sistemi di pluralia in sistemi di
pluralia in altri sistemi di pluralia è
applicabile a qualsiasi argomento a
qualsiasi cosa ora un ortaggio un altro
può venirci in aiuto per farci capire
ancora meglio cosa sono i pluralia e
come funzionano io direttamente qui dal
mercato per voi
oggi il broccolo
romanesco il broccolo romanesco è un
frattale e un frattale è un oggetto
geometrico dotato di omotetia interna
significa che la forma stessa del
broccolo si ripete al suo interno più
volte in scale più piccole e questa
ripetizione potremmo immaginarla
All'infinito E appunto non vi ricorda
qualcosa costellazioni di argomenti in
costellazioni di argomenti i pluralia
funzionano così Sono esattamente questo
abbiamo parlato di frutta di verdura di
geometria reazioni chimiche di un mio
sabato al mercato ed è pazzesco ogni
cosa è collegabile E potremmo parlare di
altri 1le
argomenti oltre alla frutta c'è un
argomento che mi interessa
particolarmente che è quello
identitario L'identità è un sistema di
pluralia complesso che ci abita ci tengo
a dire complesso Perché la nostra
identità è piena di collegamenti di
sfaccettature e cambia col tempo
cresce Ora vi racconto una storia dentro
la storia dentro la storia e quindi un
po' plurali anche
questa Sono nato 25 anni fa in un
ospedale vicino a Roma mi hanno guardato
e mi hanno assegnato un
genere genere
femminile è un po' Strano no cioè visto
così insomma sembro un ragazzo No tutto
a posto giusto capelli barba voce Un po'
Ecco e invece no non è andata così alla
mia nascita e quindi ad un certo punto
ho deciso di affrontare un percorso di
affermazione di genere il genere che mi
era stato assegnato non corrispondeva a
quello che sentivo di essere sentivo di
appartenere fortissimo al genere
maschile quindi che è successo che ad un
certo punto ho deciso di frequentare uno
psicologo per capire quale sarebbe stata
la mia strada Se era la strada giusta e
dopo qualche anno ho iniziato ad
assumere testosterone a cadenza mensile
ho iniziato una terapia ormonale e sono
cambiato tantissimo ma è uscita la barba
è cambiata la voce sono spariti i
fianchi Insomma sono diventato io cioè
proprio me e sono super consapevole e mi
sento molto molto
meglio percorso di affermazione di
genere non è un passaggio netto Da un
punto ad un altro o un salto
estremo
No è come una messa a fuoco un punto
rosso che da sfocato diventa sempre più
nitido è come
crescere semplicemente
questo affermazione di genere
appunto si
afferma ora prima di iniziare questo
viaggio avevo 1850 paure diverse e il
mio cane mi riconoscerà ancora ma sto
facendo il percorso giusto e se il
testosterone spappola il mio fegato ma
troverò mai un lavoro avrò mai una
ragazza e se diventassi
pelato buone notizie sto bene sono qua
c'ho pure i
capelli è andato tutto
ok però c'è una cosa che ancora non mi
passa e di cui ho ancora un po' paura e
cioè che il fatto di essere una persona
trans diventi la mia caratteristica
principale che mi definisca in quanto
individuo ora un altro frutto può
venirci in
aiuto il
mandarino Ora non so se vi è mai
capitato di mangiare un mandarino Penso
di sì proviamo ad immaginare che uno dei
tanti mandarini che avete mangiato vi
sia rimasto dentro incastrato da qualche
parte e che rappresenti la vostra
identità ogni spicchio è diverso ma
influenza l'altro e tutti insieme creano
un mandarino
completo questo qui è il mio
mandarino appunto l'abbiamo già detto
ogni spicchio è diverso ma rappresenta
un qualcosa e insieme formano una cosa
più grande che funziona ad esempio uno
spicchio rappresenta la scatola dei
Rigoli che sono i biscotti che mangiava
mia nonna un' altro una persona a me
molto cara un' altro ancora il viale con
la lavanda allingresso di casa sempre
dei miei nonni tutte le canzoni di
Giovanni trucchi perché è uno dei miei
cantanti preferiti un altro spicchio
ancora rappresenta la Fiat Punto di mia
madre e lì dietro c'è lo spicchio che
dice che sono una persona trans ma è
solamente uno spicchio dentro il
mandarino C'è anche tutto il resto di
me insieme formo una cosa più grande
funzionante che cresce e anche il vostro
mandarino funziona così allo stesso
identico modo certo sarà diverso da
questo ma funziona allo stesso
modo la nostra identità è un sistema di
pluralia come questo Ted come la frutta
climaterica come tutte le tematiche che
sono state
affrontate come gli atomi le molecole i
tessuti gli organi gli organismi come la
terra e l'universo le città le regioni
le province le nazioni e come altre 1le
cose che ancora non
conosciamo siamo una parte molto piccola
di un meccanismo dentro ad altri mille
meccanismi e per farlo funzionare e
farli funzionare dobbiamo fare qualcosa
dobbiamo starci in ascolto
disposti verso tutto quello che ci
circonda Anche perché c'è sempre
qualcuno che in un altro sistema di
pluralia fa qualcosa anche se
inconsciamente per far funzionare il
nostro E allora dobbiamo essere qui
dobbiamo essere in ascolto quando
parliamo nei nostri dialoghi e se le
cose non vanno scegliamo un'altra
superficie da cui vedere quello che ci
gira
attorno una persona una volta mi ha
detto che ogni esperienza è a suo modo
preziosa e allora buon ascolto No non
non ci sono altri Talk Anche perché
sarete fritti non ci sono però Buon
ascolto in generale che la vostra mente
sia sempre aperta e mangiate la
frutta
[Musica]
all